[Music]
so
hey hello
what up
you know that song
how are you guys welcome to stream
center road
good evening from indonesia nice
i actually have no idea what i'm gonna
do today
i'm up for anything that's a lie i'm not
up for anything
maybe some more i guess shut your mouth
hey nightbot in the chat what up
nightbot
bye bye
good morning from canada welcome cameron
i can do some geo gesture that's always
fun
the world sr oyster
good night from malaysia
love from malaysia all kinds of stuff
from malaysia
are you just chatting today king well i
usually start off chatting
thank you clara thank you that's
fantastic
maybe
from finland if you're going to do a
geographic villain then that's going to
be
just swamps i noticed that i got finland
once
it looked like a swampy swede tweeted
place
sweets in the chat
everyone always complains in the
comments that they're getting the stream
notification like
after i ended the stream i don't know
how that works
didn't get didn't get the notification
then how did you make it here
having a good day so far guys
mine's good yeah
all right you guys got the notification
it works sometimes
all the time
i might just watch some youtube videos
honestly throughout the year
i don't know any
swinging his knife around like he wants
to play i own this place what are you
talking about
sunny in it yeah there's sun in uk today
it's a miracle
here i am inside
today i recorded two videos and i played
some video games
and that's about it
[Music]
bye for quickly telephonies
that is such a bad joke martin
close to ben for that one not gonna lie
is that even a joke
i don't understand how [ __ ] sweden is
hotter than uk
we're further down south it makes no
sense
you ever tried uh excuses chief of
flavor
uh it's the juice isn't it yeah it's
good
i like it
how do i like live stream compared to
recording videos very different
it's fun uh phone with the chat
obviously
different energy different type of
cotton
it's 28 degrees in sweden what the [ __ ]
here's like the hottest it's been for
weeks and it's what
18. how hot
is right 23 all right fine
felix do i like kombucha i'm so glad you
asked because
i love kombucha although if you ever
seen how they make it
you'll throw up it's disgusting i
remember watching a shark tank episode
where
someone's pitch was that you can make
your own kombucha
and it looks like the most vile
disgusting thing i've ever seen
31 in finland god damn
i look like a restaurant owner why thank
you
me and martha went to a michelin star
restaurant for the first time
and the food was incredible but the menu
was like
i didn't understand what any of it was
and i i was you know when the menu is
just
what the [ __ ] is this plant i never
heard in my life what is this the sauce
i don't [ __ ] know
so we ordered it and i i
and i loved it but after the waiter came
and asked how did you like it and i said
i was
surprisingly good and she was like
surprising
i was like that's not what i meant just
i didn't know what it was
and then um yeah
i don't know what i ate that's the
problem
i should grow a ponytail nah i'm good
thanks though
no i wasn't going to ramsey
is that a rich people restaurant
actually the price was reasonable
i would say
write anything by doug never heard
what hogwarts house to identify don't
don't you dare bring that up
i'm still mad about it
have i been outside today thanks for
asking yes twice i walk my dogs
reasonable two thousand dollar me i
think it was like 25 pounds
which for a fancy restaurant doesn't
seem like outrageous
you did surprisingly good in the animes
quiz thanks
i feel like i knew yokohama i was kind
of mad about that
and the islands i felt like i knew
actually as well
i need to buy a hufflepuff scarf
honestly they don't look that bad out of
all the scarves hufflepuff scarf
i'm okay with
i look like a mafia boss thanks what the
[ __ ]
all right i got a message
no i then i just got another challenge
in world blitz
sorry mom i'm streaming
what am i playing today i don't know i
have a few games
gta rp my postman told me about a new
gta is that where you guys were talking
about
nice black shirt today thanks brand new
one
i love your shade of black shirt thanks
it's a new it's not new rp or role play
oh well apparently the new gta is out
for 2025
my according to my postman and i'm like
don't [ __ ] tell me
about a game that's gonna come out in
four years i don't care
yeah honestly i kind of want to play
holly bridge again i might do that
and embarrass myself publicly
sweden is apparently super hot [ __ ] all
right
i wish i was in sweden right now
it's like shirt hey i know
play the one where you build ski lips
what is that is it the same but
ski lift maybe that's my where my talent
lies
so please do you have any base merch i
do but it's too hot
for me to work
what up ola
i think i put the wrong lenses in i can
like barely see chats
all fuzzy
did i work out today no today's my day
off my last day off then tomorrow chess
thanks for asking
thank you
will we be getting pewdiepie knife yes
absolutely first the gun though
pewdiepie machine gun
try calisthenics i thought about it but
i like my routine right now
i don't see a reason to change it
i've incorporated a candle in my workout
which is fun
[Music]
then pewdiepie hand grenade pewdiepie
nuke that'd be
sick i did a video where
i rated top 10 ways for humanity to die
and i'll have to reshoot it and add the
pewdiepie atom bomb
that'd be the most deadliest one of all
i picked up during olympic weightlifting
what's the difference with olympia
oh well that should have been obvious
[Music]
i can't deep throat my microphone
anymore because youtube
has decided that they will demonetize my
video if i do it
that's the only reason that's the only
thing stopping me from doing it right
now
however my keyboard there's nothing
stopping me from annihilating
i got some custom kitkat for it and it
looks so
good they're nice warm redness
i love it so happy with this keyboard
check it out
there's nothing stopping me
deep throating i think i can put this in
my mouth
i can really talk
ah one day
one day
sorry you have to see that
edgar hair was on the g fuel cup and now
it's in my mom
[Music]
big mouth baby i also have a big tongue
tastes so good nice and salty
i'm coming into this [ __ ] stream now
i'm like what the [ __ ] is he doing i
don't know
tongue reveal
i feel like i don't know if it's true
but i feel like when i was young
i was i thought it was so cool to have a
big tongue so i trained myself to like
try and pull it out as much as i could
and i don't know if that made a name
[Music]
thing
i don't know it's a [ __ ] music
some trap [ __ ]
peaks and valleys
that's a size
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] it let's go with this
i miss my play through what the [ __ ]
chats good old jazz
but do i like use of slash obviously
it's the greatest flavor
[Music]
play some toxic avengers what is that
can you taste more with your larger
tongue absolutely at least
five percent
dude i really comment but i've been
watching for years thanks for the last
thank you for watching lockdown23 and i
[Music]
nicer thanks
okay am i excited for it nothing there's
nothing
there's no excitement
host malone calls you out in this new
song hell yeah
what is he saying pewdiepie pewdiepie's
the [ __ ] greatest
y'all hate the game baby
right says well thanks for asking
[Music]
nah he said who's joe that's a good meme
i remember that mean
love you peter thanks for being awesome
same thing right back at you
[Music]
yeah it's a squid industry trainer
what's the plan for today's life i don't
know
we'll see
hey pizz could you wish my friend cn
happy birthday happy birthday
from daniel have a great one
[Music]
i have changed my black shirt
i think
yeah we could play a power wash game
that was kind of fun
can you bless my baby no can't do that
that's illegal
how many black shirts do i own seven
obviously
i'm not gonna suck the mic i'll suck
anything else you want
uh excuse me that was gross i apologize
i forgot i was live it happened
let's just forget about it let's move
on
could you give a quick shout out to k
diamond from
k diamond style to himself or herself
start a playthrough what game do you
want me to do a playthrough of then
i have no updates on the gundam it looks
the same as it did
i don't know how to get customed
accounts i don't understand
i looked everywhere i ordered one and
they canceled my order
so i wanted to put like swedish military
[ __ ] on it an ikea logos on it
because that's what's gonna make it cool
i was also thinking
having a from like the ikea bag
that typical blue bag [ __ ] have that as
a cape
could be cool make a little cape for him
or a scarf or i don't [ __ ] know
i think that'll be cool
i heard it from my mom that in hawaii
and if anyone is watching from hawaii
please let me know that
since they don't have ikea in hawaii
it's become like a really cool thing to
have the ikea bags in hawaii
that to me is just so funny
hell yeah the ikea i mean they're great
[ __ ] banks not gonna lie
that's so sad living in like paradise
but there's no ikea
you know
ikea packs are cool regardless
you're not like here in india
i didn't realize you didn't have
furniture in india and that's crazy
[Music]
i like this chocolate called dime from
ikea oh [ __ ] dime i forgot
that's a classic swedish chocolate
they saw that at ikea
we have a canyon yet okay that makes
sense then
the small pencils you can take it out
here
that's the best reason to go to ikea
just grab as many of those small pens
as possible no i can't philippines
oh or philippines
where do you store all your books and
sleep at night
on the floor
no ikea gang no i can't south america ah
what you're breaking my heart
here we don't have ikea well that could
mean anywhere
no i can't in brazil oh all right i'd
stop they said don't tell me
just don't tell me anymore
very upsetting
so
now like here i know life what's the
point honestly all right let's play a
game
i'll start with some poly bridge because
i kind of want to play that you guys are
okay with that yeah
cool
oh look let's play some just eye already
i've been meaning to stream that
but i have no friends to play it with
[Music]
it's made by
double moose games which i own part of
so
very cool i played it with uh
jack and ken that was hilarious but ken
is in australia and
jack is uh he's done
he's not done i don't know why i said
that oh god
this feel weird playing a game with
other people that like
all benefit from
right and they don't get anything
but it is really fun let's play it are
you guys not we can play co-op actually
i can play with you guys
select your boomer or should i pick
i like wall-e he's got attitude
come on let's get to
nothing happened to jack i just made a
joke
download it and i'll play with you guys
[Music]
it's called just die already
how the [ __ ] do i get up there we go
nice okay so you grabs that no that's
ragdoll
there we go i totally forgot the
controls
i can't grab the chicken
censored gore no thanks come on
i saw controls as soon as i clicked away
oh that's it okay
oh it literally just shut up
don't turn out the wine hold on
let's go so what does he have to do
all right i gotta kill myself
golden key all right
sun glitcher what's happening ah
they're in the sun hold up let me say
i lost my ac remote and
i am dying i don't know how i lost
lose a remote it makes no [ __ ] sense
why would it ever leave this room i've
looked everywhere here we go what
[Music]
oh whoa they have all the levels
oh sick okay i'll host the game
and then if you guys want to join you
can join
oh the depth all right free for all
it's a
the free-for-all is rdjf
and while i wait
i will get a g fuel
good
[Music]
all right we got some people let's wait
for uh one more there we go
dicks mustang good names
i don't know how you okay start the game
score points by killing players on the
other teams the first play to reach
don't slap me don't [ __ ] ah no
why would you do that give me
give it back give it back give it back
no no
all right let's start here we go game
starts
it's free fro okay nice nice nice
overload
what does that do
then what's oh gun gun gun gun grab it
there we go you're done you're done
son new call of duty oh
how are you are you alive he's alive
he's
killed what the [ __ ] do i
shoot it's i'm shooting balloons oh of
course
yeah i get [ __ ] no leg gang
i want a better weapon
what is happening i'm stuck no i'm good
no he's got the bomb he's got the bomb
let's get the one
it's not going great for oh we got the
swedish sign what the [ __ ] is this a
shield
oh cool i have a shield
okay what is what the [ __ ] is this nail
gun
oh this is it no no no no
no no mine
oh i'm so sorry old lady
no i had it i had it
i keep dropping it
yes yeah fun yeah
let's go
oh hey you're supposed to be dead stop
stop
let's go you guys are noobs
this is me versus star sapphire and i
don't know where he is
what the [ __ ] was that
what do i do with this i go faster
oh mo p as [ __ ] now
headshot hey headshot
no he healed his head [ __ ] you
there we go
i'm i'm schooling you guys
this is pathetic you want the nade
you want the name
whoa whoa she's got a harpoon
anchor whatever it is
dude i'm so happy
oh no get his legs
yeah there you go get their legs [ __ ]
your legs
now get our legs
i'm trying to hit our legs
come on that was a leg shot and you know
it stop
stop old man
oh it's a flashbang we're good
guys that was a massacre
uh
okay swingers arena
did i not change
yeah okay persev to vote okay i got you
literally just legs running all right
all right new map zero dash baby
oh so this is a team one okay that's
fine let's do more kills
i'll be some more people can join this
one
i'll wait for uh
people to join sorry the code is rdja
no are we still just four people
someone else gotta join red team i'll do
it
how do i start did i started i think i
started it
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] up
all right what do we got dynamite
are these portals
a jump high
[ __ ] go away no teammate teammate your
teammate give me
shield i don't want that this looks good
[ __ ] no ah you died as well
yeah this game is out on switch as well
the anchor sucks oh god she's got a good
weapon
dude denzel you got to do something man
yeah get the anchor
oh my god i'm sorry don't go near me
we're in the same team
get the hell
god the ragdoll physics makes this what
are the rings am i supposed to grab them
oh for [ __ ] sake
okay i think i understand
i had to hold down
the batter weapons are reached
by swinging this is not a newbie map
what
have we not started i haven't started
the game oh my [ __ ] god
i'm so dumb okay good that means zero
deaths
here we go he's got a shield
and she died
he doesn't see me
oh [ __ ] come here granny
come here granny give me granny
come on grains
where you going you want a baseball bat
yeah jump
[Laughter]
the slot wait someone changed team it's
literally
guys all right fine we'll play it out
wait who am i i'm red team okay it works
now good he changed back
it's got a jet pack what are you gonna
do with that
stop
she was the baseball player you ain't
getting the people back
dream on it no
oh no
[ __ ]
shield yes the best gun
the best gun yes
let's let the slaughter begin
let's go
[Music]
dodge face [ __ ] oh god she can [ __ ]
nice what are you gonna do with those
legs hey
no don't no shield that was good
get their legs boy
so hard to hit him stop
yeah oh [ __ ] it's got a sword
no stop healing you nerd [ __ ]
i'm bleeding out
i'm not losing this gun
yeah that's right you got greedy is she
alive
confirm the kill
thank again
oh he's got a gun not anymore
i want that gun
that's a swing [ __ ] you are not killing
me
no sir there we go
give me back my gun
she tried to pick it up
oh god it's kind of close
no it's not no it's not
boy
weapon seems a bit unbalanced
oh you're gonna die don't even even
hey dude i'm on your side why did you
stop
why did you do this stop she's got a gun
graves good good i'm sorry you stood in
the
no go legs go legs
i can still make it i can still make it
no no no no i can still make it yes
[Music]
give me the burger give me that [ __ ] oh
god
two nine all right all right we're close
but we gotta finish this up
all right i got this
all right well that killed thing he's
alive he's alive
no no no
no you're not getting that you're not
getting the burger
come back here come back here come stop
you can't do the jump
stop yes
let's [ __ ] go
all right let's open up for some other
people
that's fun
[Music]
okay
uh let's do crazy joes
you have to pick apples the crazy joe
players have to defend the farm
from apple pickers by killing them
before they steal
okay
[Music]
how
i'm still alive thank you very much
i'll put the game in the title people
keep asking
[Music]
legma has joined all right everyone's
saying let's do this
pick a team don't pick my team nerds
[Music]
there we go
gun i want a gun
okay we got apples
kind of okay i got an apple
pick them up dude okay i got four i'm
getting fatter
from apples how many calories in an
apple bro
look at this dude
no no i want to be fat please
health pack elf pack
i gotta put the apples here got it
let's go skinny gang
[Music]
pick them up
oh i'm so big
you can't stop me
[Music]
you can't stop this menace where the
[ __ ] are your apples
where the [ __ ] is the apples there gold
mine
oh i'm just gonna be so fat dude
i'm huge look at this dude
oh god i'm so slow okay we gotta make it
back
gotta bring back the apples but they got
a gun
they're camping they're camping
[Music]
okay go go go go
go go come on
[Music]
oh come on he hasn't seen me he saw me
go apples apples yes
let's go yeah
one leg gang can't stop me
oh they're my old limbs that's [ __ ]
disgusting
all right more apples oh here we go
[Music]
[ __ ] off barrel
don't shoot me don't shoot me don't
shoot me
don't shoot me don't shoot me i just
want to give apples that's all i want uh
i'm still alive i'm still alive
i'm still alive i'm still alive you
can't kill this
i'm still good you kick you'll never
kill me
i can fart [ __ ] amazing stop
stop i'm nothing
all right we got 20 apples
picking the same team as me
[Music]
or maybe it makes sense as there's one
defender actually
whoa you can do that awesome
[Music]
okay
oh there's different modes okay
still a new one sorry
[Music]
um let's do a sandbox
can i allow crossplay okay how do i do
that
ah
code of conduct nice
all right there's code
what is this
[Music]
i get some help
can i get some [ __ ] help
what have i done i'm sorry
[Applause]
make it stop all right guys guys we got
to progress in the game
stop stopping with fire enough fire
[ __ ] sake okay
there we go someone did it golden key
all right we
find the golden key guys
i don't remember it could be here
i think they think they can lock me up
in here with these flimsy planks if only
i had a sharp
object here we go i got a sharp object
all right sharp object uh spoon
his legs
uh bear trap
maybe in the fridge
is that in what's what's around my neck
did i break my
el
not again not again not again don't go
near me
there's a crab i want the crime i want
the crime
i want the crime
[Applause]
oh the crab ate me i was like how the
[ __ ] did i die alright guys
guys stop stop all right someone knows
what they're doing thank you
there we go let's keep going
i think you need to go
turn on the electricity right there it
is here guys
oh my [ __ ] god stop
stop oh my god the oil spillage
there we go it's in here
[Music]
i'm fine honestly all right
so now we can go
stop hitting me oh dare you now we can
go out
[Music]
oh it becomes red
i got a fish stop
hitting me i'm stuck in the tank
i'm too short i can't get out
all right
see those bubbles are standing around
celebrating i hate them all this okay
all right
one
oh yeah
oh we're still locked in i remember this
let's kill her
that's payback young
[Music]
sorry sorry
this game is a bit grime
hey don't slap me what do i do
[Music]
there's another way out
it sucks put on some better music some
trash music
don't you dare destroy this party by
going around hurting out of theirs
it'll ruin our good time okay
what's that i don't know why i asked oh
there's another cd let's put it in
might be an easter egg
oh sick
mate let me put it in
what did you do
[Music]
is it in my nose
what is blink a lot doing
[Music]
get down from the ceiling blink
maybe i should try and hit another rest
in here then the nurse have to throw me
out
oh that's it all right
we just got a punch then
how do i punch them i gotta punch them
there we go
there we go we're free
[Music]
there's our boys let's go
i'm gonna understand why they kicked us
out this is where the cool stuff is
killer boomer today agreed
oh we gotta talk to the homeless guy
all right yeah yeah you got a bucket
list and then you unlock stuff that's
right
uh huh hey we got a salami
i don't play this with ken again it was
fun in jack
hey what the [ __ ] why is he hitting me
i remember there was like a giant hammer
here somewhere
beautiful this is my soundcloud
guys check out my soundcloud
[Music]
please oh you got a problem this is my
spot i've been here longer than you [ __ ]
up
ah
can't stop me from playing
you can't stop art
he's got a knife i kind of want that
oh discovered a new area this is
cyberpunk actually yeah reskin model
they updated the game finally it's way
better now
[Music]
oh cool i haven't seen this then
oh sword give me that [ __ ]
i'm fine can i grab it no i can't yeah
i'll respawn
what's up blink lot are you doing all
right mate
i'll pick you up mei let's go
you're good you're good
i'll find you a health pack
damn no [ __ ] the crimes
so many cool areas
i haven't seen any of this what's all
this thing
i'm not going to die from a crane all
right so these you can buy this stuff
[Laughter]
don't shoot me do not shoot me
we have to say blink
do you feel
come here blink we'll save you
i'll save you blank whoops
oh you're fine you're fine
ooh gun store just miserable
oh we need a [ __ ] we need a key for that
all right
oh i mean i walked in circles amazing
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh no wait i can pee
oh [ __ ] now
[Music]
i'm still alive
hey mate
oh god my thing is spinning so much
okay no motor function gang let's
go whoa
[Music]
what's all this thing
[ __ ] you oh he's wearing cloak merch
he is what oh why do they hit me
[ __ ] i didn't mean to do that
whoa nice shot that was close
ah [ __ ] up all right now i can fit
there we go
oh yeah
[Laughter]
i thought there was something inside
all right it's gotta be something here
all right whoa all right play me young
[ __ ] might seem a bit unfair since he
has no legs
sorry mate
it goes so much higher than i think
oh i lost my arm that's fine at least i
have legs
unlike some people all right should aim
it there then
[ __ ] off
all right three points oh my god he
whoa
imagine having legs can't relate
he keeps trying to take it it bounces
too much
ah [ __ ] yeah i got denied man oh casino
hmm oh hey man
oh it's a fancy place we got the key
we probably need that for something
another key what's with all the keys
sushi fries i remember this
oh my god stop
[Music]
[ __ ] oh these are the people that keep
throwing you in the trash don't they
stop
what the [ __ ] is he doing
oh oh we got a taser now
oh no it's nice
axe nice
i can't respawn
why can't i respawn kill me someone kill
me
i'm dead i can sort of move
blink help me thanks blink no
save me save me please
please
help me
if i change character there we go that
word
oh oh let's go
throw me throw me
there we go i'm ready
let's go where does it take me
the [ __ ] can't roll back too much
there we go oh oh it's one of these [ __ ]
yeah i'm fine honestly
can i drive these
no
oh [ __ ] yeah
oh hell yeah oops
whoops whoops
guys oh no no
we're fine guys get one they're over
here
there's two more
what the [ __ ] get out of here
get out of here robo wars
where did you get that
no no no no
oh what the [ __ ] [ __ ] i want that one
get up get up
oh you challenged me blink
[ __ ] you won
[ __ ]
realistic physics oh no
oh no why is our mine field
just don't touch anything i'll be fine
okay i can make it out of line
just be careful be careful
there we go don't do it star it's not
worth it oh maybe there's stuff over
here
ooh new area what are those
[Music]
cohen park cool
i can get a salami
are they supposed to be she they're so
cute
oh work the gun now banana gun
what are you doing with that get the
[ __ ] out of here
the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here get
out of here
i broke my spine it's fine
this is mine there we go
what are they doing
oh that looks [ __ ] up
no there we go banana gun
no snx banana guy
i'll set a trap around
banana gun [ __ ] sucks there you go
got him
i like how he swears as if he doesn't
want to get demonetized
oh what is this oh
oh don't [ __ ] with me oh god what
happened to me i'm allergic
[Laughter]
i don't know i like your reaction
the [ __ ] are these pathetic ass guns
oh look at him he's all [ __ ] up
don't touch me don't touch me
scum
oh here comes broken spine lady
with her sausage
oh my god
listen here listen here let go me
look where you date i want to get
allergic again
bruh
[Laughter]
no
oh look at that i'm dream speed run
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that a magnet gun
stop stop it stop it
stop stop it i'm leaving
[Music]
all right let's check out more areas
that's cool
what's with what are these areas
oh my [ __ ] god
i don't know what i was expecting oh
sorry
uh real gun please thank you
america be like oh what the [ __ ]
i'll help you there you go whoa
wow
please i have a child
i think you can go to the rooftops yeah
let me try it
[Music]
oh sorry
sorry lady new girlfriend reveal
there she is we love each other
where are we going
where are you taking me
i'll go anywhere you want
[Applause]
[ __ ]
she's fine never mind
oh [ __ ] i got so much stuff i didn't
realize
ooh katana
get dynamite uh bro stop stop grab me
please
come on thank you
game reminds me of the game called pain
yeah i think that sums it up
all right can we get up here
there we go what the [ __ ] did you
what is happening there
oh i want to try that it's the mines
isn't it
give me the car oh you [ __ ] up all the
cars didn't you
there he is whoops
there we go
there's a sheep in there what the [ __ ]
what's all this oh no
what have i done
what the [ __ ] is this
oh sorry
[Music]
how bad things are amount of boomers
i [ __ ] knew it
that's what you get for always shooting
me
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go here we go
no i wanted to fly with it
this game's ridiculous
all right let's oh dude you're so fat
please can i have it
jesus
[Music]
stop i'm in hell oh god i didn't
i didn't mean to
oh god i'm gonna break my legs save the
fall
save that
hey i'm playing a car wash simulator
whatever the [ __ ] it was called
you wait i'm lucky you're just walking
around with no legs
and the fattest [ __ ] guns i've ever
seen
let's clean you up baby
there you go
[Music]
oh there's a jump here
gotta do that gem we need a car
[ __ ]
oh here's where you get up in the
buildings
oh that was clean
there's actual ladder climbing mechanics
i don't think this is there we go it's
like clop
there we go there we go
nice
now what oh there it is
give me that
nice
[ __ ] break the fall there you go
this guy walks like a toddler dude he's
old cut him some slack
milk that couldn't possibly kill me
i can pee nice
all right
[Applause]
warm milk you gotta jump oh that was
clean
jump oh oh oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] yes [ __ ]
wanna get up there there it is oh
no no no no no
[ __ ] oh god what have i done
oh that's a tricky jump
no [ __ ] it's so hard
hey
oh that's perfect we can get up there
stop grabbing it oh young hold it hold
it like that and i'll jump on it
oh that works great thanks
there we go
mirrors h3
this is where i was no yeah
we go here no it was a [ __ ] trap
[ __ ]
i'm still alive i'm still alive
here we go just got to commit guys
oh we're [ __ ] back here god damn it
all right
i didn't break anything all right what
do we got in here
oh god what is in there yeah
why is he naked
[Music]
big carrot bye all right i'll get a big
carrot
3.99 annoying grandma
399.99
eat some quiet long farm nice
all right what else can we get let's try
this
can i try it on you i'll try it on him
oh it's ready oh it's [ __ ] this is
thanos glove
oh
he wants more
[Music]
oh sorry oh oh oh
sorry
uh huh okay
what is the trampoline doing in here
yeah nah
damn it let go of the trampoline
god
um
oh it's a swedish post uh looking one
kind of
maybe
here comes the power grow a shark just
add water
i'm gonna try that too
okay we gotta find water
what are these
oh it's a balloon gun nice all right
let's find you some water mr shark
you guys remember can we shoot those on
the cars
bye bye [ __ ] bye
bye sweetie shot dog from yeah
bye
whoa you ride the vespas
bye all right you want a flying vespa i
got you
[Music]
it's like a shitty disney movie no
okay okay okay guys we need to find
water for the shark please
please behave
there we go how am i riding this
[Music]
oh you see that dodge holy [ __ ]
whoa i'm out of control you can't hit
grandpa he's got too much power
i'm trying what
i'm a menace
are they dodging me what's happening
no they weren't what the [ __ ]
[Music]
oh man all right here's the gun one
okay i can get a gun dynamite lame
thrower all right all right
[Music]
i'm holding on to this [ __ ] piece of
glass
okay
okay young monsters young monsters can
you shoot off my legs
shoot my legs shoot my legs what the
[ __ ] am i looking at dude
shoot my legs bro shoot my legs come on
shoot my legs shoot my legs come on
shoot shoot my legs
shoot my legs shoot my legs
shoot my legs there you go one more
there you go all right
thanks that's enough
now we ride the bike whoa i'm faster now
how the [ __ ] does
oh trampoline with the bike let's go
this game is out of [ __ ] control look
at this [ __ ]
no
i'm not even holding on to it
the car is trapped
yeah look at me go i'm so sassy
i'm so sassy yeah
i got so much attitude let's go
that is so dumb
perfect physics perfect physics in this
game
all right let's head back oh [ __ ] not
the tram
oh my oh my
[Music]
okay
oh no i lost shark [ __ ] damn
where was it let's get the shark back
it's like from one of the shops today
yeah what do they sell
sweaters i guess i could have guessed
blank do you know where the or sapphire
do you know where the shark is oh here's
the gun
hey nice bike bro
you can rocket jump with this
the possibilities are endless i want the
shark i want the shark where did i leave
it
[Music]
okay i'm kind of glad that didn't work
to be honest
that took care of that
do you have the shark star
let me get the vespa
this is what i'm talking about
oh god it's hard to steer
what's the [ __ ]
did you shoot a cop [ __ ] sorry
he threw me out earlier that's why there
we go
let's get up the stairs
can i get a push
can i get a push [ __ ]
honestly i'm fine
yes it worked
whoa that was sick here it comes
go grandpa let's go that was sick
it's like a weird backstory on boomers
no no no no don't hurt me i'm sweetie
hey russian bros what does that mean
all right that's my stop what do we have
here
i saw some cool guns i remember what
just happened
no who did that oh
[ __ ] young don't do that
don't do that
blank you might wanna sorry blink
oh i'll make a new code sorry guys i
forgot
oh yeah who's leaving without you there
we go here's the best gun in the game
no i'm not shooting you what are you
doing stop it
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry sorry not sorry
alright works
whoa
[ __ ]
i push down some fireworks nice
now i can grab them
i love that
okay let's make a new code thanks for
playing blink lodge star safari and
young monsters
okay
oh save for sure
oh he left what a legend sorry blink
would you mind
leaving so other people can join oh
you guys are always so nice
[ __ ] horror game
what up denzel
are you doing denzel figuring out the
controls
i'll just take a nap [ __ ] sake
i don't know why i expected that to be
oh let's try the katana now it's
cyberpunk
hey let's grab a bike denzel
no i made it one no no
not the shark not the shark please not
the shark please please
please please get out of the water
no no i'm so scared
why is that shark so scary okay we can
lower the bridge
all right welcome kai and marius
[Music]
all right we're in the japanese quarters
no all the crabs there was
uh oh my god
help help me help
me there you go thanks watch out for the
crimes
what is this the obliter oh it's this
one
[ __ ] let's go guys
let's all go together to nangiola
it's been an honor
never going near a crime shot again yet
what's all this thing
you just chop me
oh we're here okay i can do the jump
[Music]
[ __ ] i'm gonna die i'm gonna die i'm
gonna die
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die sami kai
save me save me
safe that's [ __ ] up
no
oh help me help me get up it's like
titanic
[Music]
oh it was you kelly right that was fun
playing yeah
there's a chest here that's got to be
something
oh my god the [ __ ] crab getting my
knees
oh the bridge is lowered nice
democracy surplus one what surplus
nope kai kai i know you want to hit me
with that leg but i
i implore you not to do it okay let's do
this jump
your turn oh i got bad news for you kai
swim whoa he made it let's go
again
let's push him in [ __ ]
[ __ ] boy the sharks
he's fine
thanks for super fun gamepads i was
blank cozy pixels thanks for playing
that was awesome
made my day awesome
oh no oh oh oh this got to be good right
[ __ ] you i can grab it again
okay
where was it here
yeah golden sewer
it's a regular sword
okay oh
need a key we do know there's keys in
the casino
or is that a key that's a key right
there don't
stop [ __ ] my legs up crabs all right
guys let's get the key
oh my god
you got the key all right let's open up
here
nice all right what do we got
all right someone stand in front of the
cannon
what the [ __ ] do they do
all right maybe you have to load them
yeah you promise to load them here we go
there we go now it's loaded all right
sign in front
why
all right fine i'll get a fat fish
what are you doing with that what's all
this thing
have you heard about a sushi gate those
jerks need to be brought down use a
cannon and shoot the giant sign over
there
oh guys we need to bring the cannon here
and shoot what giant sign
there's [ __ ] jet skis over there i
need that
you have to shoot the sign down across
the pier
[Music]
i'll help you mate let's go
[ __ ] it's a little heavy okay we have a
cannon we just i
need balls
can we shoot this one
[Music]
i don't understand oh my [ __ ] god
guys got it
what happens when you do it
i want to get the jet skis
oh oh
[Music]
you're right all right come on we should
be able to do this
there we go there we go
all right guys get the cannonballs
and we got this
what are you doing denzel
denzel is the cannonball
okay oh nice
put him in
put them in put them in
[ __ ] put them in
put them in put them in kai put them in
kai put it in kai
put it in kai okay put it in
caillou miss how the [ __ ] do i shoot
them
maybe you need to light them that would
make sense
is there a fire here or something
does anyone have a there's a fire
i got it guys i got the fire
i got it i got it make sure it's loaded
[Applause]
there we go holy [ __ ] it worked
but we missed [ __ ]
oh no the shark's coming save
they're so close to great
all i wanted was jet skis
is there anywhere to get there without
let's try it
easy
come on down style you can do this jump
knight
oh okay you can jump here parkour
[ __ ] [ __ ] save me denzel got it
same with zenzel save us
i can make it i can make it i can make
it hi sacrifice yourself
he is safe against get out there
oh sorry i'm sorry
all right i appreciate you trying all
right how do you do it
yes let's go
come on kai
oh kai oh no
oh you can just swim
oh we got the bridge down nice
guys let's get to the jet skis
secret here there's so much to explore
yeah battery here
yeah in these hoes what does that mean
all right we're one step away from the
jet skis
[Music]
what the [ __ ] are you sorry
oh my god stop running into my sword
there yes don't do it don't do it
all right i'll join you floor gang
[Music]
i'm still alive outplayed
all right how do we cross [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm always so lost where are we now
here
oh there it is
[ __ ] we're so close how do we get there
maybe from the roof
of course guys this way go to the korean
[Music]
bar
they're singing a swedish song
so you'd sing in denzel here we go we
got this
no i slipped no
no
wait i made it it worked
[Music]
jet skis just case before the cops get
me
yes oh [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] yeah it's
better than i thought
let's go what is that nice fish
yeah let's go
[ __ ] yeah
oh
oh no
[Music]
it was worth it no i lost the jet ski
now
no it wasn't worth it
bring back the jet skis i can get it i
can get him i can save him don't worry
this is how i swim don't worry about it
oh [ __ ] oh
okay
[Music]
what is this a hat
well well well looks like i'm the mayor
now
that's right denzel hey
excuse me
i'm thirsty i'm gonna get a drink
what did you do who killed me
who did it i can see did someone push me
in
what the [ __ ] did you do i'll watch the
replay i know what you did
go back what happened here
you [ __ ]
denzel not denzel denzel would not do
that to me
marriott he peed on me yeah
[ __ ] he's taunting me
he peed on you not kind of epic not
gonna lie
what the [ __ ] i won't forget this
oh yeah i hope that since
[Laughter]
don't even come near me you scum
all right i'll forgive you it's okay
excuse me two double sneeze i don't know
where
uh is this the shark
no it's a fish
sorry
watch out for the trap kai oh guys
let's go in this
amazing hell yeah
we lost various oh he's coming
it's a mate one guy has to push it
obviously fine i'll do it myself
amazing oh yeah
pete gaming doesn't get better
oh how how did that happen
is everyone fine no we're fine
bury us what's in the tree house
guys check out check out the triads i
don't have arms
i can't climb it
i think you stepped on something then uh
kai okay various is on it watch out for
the bees
climbing skills happening here
all right what's up there
what did you find
okay
all right should we switch out players
again thanks for playing guys it's fun
if you guys don't mind leaving then
other people can join i don't have to
make a new one
thank you varys
thanks guys so polite look at you guys
i enjoy playing with you guys
every time i sneeze i have to blow my
nose
okay what up doctor jam you all right
does he know i'm not afk anymore what
are you doing
yeah you you like on my head let go of
my head
we got dr jam crimpy and man eats
pants or man eats pants
or may needs pants
what are you doing in here hey baby
murdered
murder for these pride oh i thought i
could get it can i get this one how did
the other player get it
is that the trampoline it's still
hello right um
all right how does one operate this it's
gotta be for something right
what's in the box
oh it was close
that's what you get i'm telling martial
what did i oh
[ __ ] what up crimpy
what up dr jeff all right we're doing it
we're playing like this
i feel like we didn't check this area
oh let's all grab one and roll around in
them
push me push me
how is this killing me i'm not even
dying
i want to push it down can you push it
down
what the [ __ ] i'll push you
there you go someone get inside when he
rolls down
okay maybe not oh i thought it would fly
kimbee made a pro move [ __ ] sake
i can grab this ah
cool
love that sound oh my god i just want to
cross
there we go there promo
there's got to be something with the
sheeps okay
got it
i got a toy shop shark it's mine
water anyone
it's gotta be stuff here that we haven't
explored
oh there's a ticket dick
let's get it nailed it the [ __ ] sake
nice
poor sheep
he's forever stuck hey don't hit me
oh they karma that's karma right there
yeah baby
how you doing
likes are overrated
oh nope i love that trampoline for so
long ago it's just like causing me
oh you can get up there
[Music]
should check it out how
oh okay let me respawn here
manny pens watch out for that thing
be careful um
what'd i tell you what did i tell you
grimpy can i oh [ __ ]
all right
all right i'm fine
i just took it all right
no [ __ ] [ __ ] where am i
there we go
there we go there we go
olympic uh [ __ ] sake
damn it
[Music]
do not hit me with your intestines
please
all i want oh thanks
let go of them
i want to get up here
there we go there
put your arm up there we go
almost there almost there
i had it yes
oh my crotch there we go
yes let's go what the [ __ ] how did
all right
oh
i'm so bad get up
there you go there you go
okay and then let me get the balloon gun
[ __ ] where did i forgot where that was i
don't know
all right
what the [ __ ] is happening here
nope wrong end okay try it try it manny
where you going where are you going now
show us the way hey crimpy
do it coward do it
[Laughter]
wow
there's gotta be something here oh here
we go
a baseball amazing
[ __ ]
hey look at that amazing
oh look we're back [ __ ] here what are
you doing
doctor that's not how you
amazing
crimpy's damien where
oh my leg nice he's gonna throw me off
[ __ ] [ __ ] up how do i get past her guys
i need a tank here
okay thank him thank him thank him let's
go
let's go it worked thanks oh we're just
[Laughter]
[Music]
here
all right [ __ ] me up
[Music]
what up damon
okay so there's
it's the docs park because there's uh
four areas
have we done them all have we visited
them all
i feel like we haven't been here
the [ __ ] did i just witness
what is that teeth for meds are you even
going to live long enough to use those
just saying fair that's a good argument
oh let's plug this in
no
there we go what does that do must have
done
that guy's still flying around
oh man doctor jam no mercy
what i do i plugged it in sir
can i do something lower the ladder
go back to where you get the jet skis
and go down the hot tub tunnel
oh okay but first i gotta get this
person's hat
give me your hat give me your hat please
[ __ ] it it's like toad's hat it's stuck
to his head
that's what you get that's what you
[ __ ] get
she's fine is that a leaf blower
what is this oh it's one of these
a crimpy
sorry i don't know why i did that
all right let's go to uh
i did it earlier and it shocked the guy
up there what
hot tubs let's go to hot tubs
nice oh manny's pants rip
i use water we can put the shark here
i mean there's water everywhere and i
think about it that's a crocodile
and we're not going to talk about that
nice very nice
oh you're dead you're dead here grab my
hand grab my hand
grab my hand grab my hand bro grab my
hand
bro grab my hand we ain't got time
um bro
rip
where were the jet skis
take my good hands
it's over here wasn't it yeah a little
tricky jump
you guys can do it
you're both mate you can swim you can
swim because you win because you can do
it you're good
you can do it swim fast swim fast swim
fast
come on creepy wrong way crimpy turn
around crimpy creepy creepy
other way there now no crimping now
don't bring the boat grab it just sweat
all right it happens
oh dude man it's got a gun
okay how do i get past here again i
forgot we go
up that's right how did we get up
oh through the korean bar guys sorry
wait i didn't check in here actually
or did i
[Music]
how does pants taste like tell me all
about it
okay here we go
that's how it's done
no [ __ ] i completely forgot
i remember there was like a way easier
way to do it can i
walk on this
maybe i can just jump it
let's win swim
swim oh that's right i never [ __ ]
i never did it i just respawn and then i
end up here there we go
all right get in the hot tub guys
i'll wait for you to come over
oh shotgun
oh fire one heavy mallet
b grenade what happened to the water
what the [ __ ] is this jetski
bye okay get on hold on to it
just hold on to it i'll drive us
[Music]
just hold on just hold on to me everyone
hold on to me howard holds us
hold on hold it doesn't work
[Music]
it doesn't work i can't drive it you're
too fat you're too
fat all right let go i go away
i need to go stop
let me go
fine
oh my doctor let go
please doctor please i beg
there we go oh it worked for a second it
works oh it works
[ __ ] off god damn it
oh my stop oh i got it
how am i alive
there we go
there we almost we were so close to
greatness
i am so [ __ ] up every bone
that is left in my butt
right in the ass you'll regret that
yo
hey i got my my new leg
don't do it don't do it
hey can't hit me at can't hit me
can't do it
well you can use them to climb that's
kind of cool all right what's through
here then you
exit or it's nothing it looks like
nothing
no oh
i'm back baby
[ __ ] oh i made it i'm alive
thanks for
[Laughter]
oh sacrifice oh so sad the jet skis we
[ __ ] them up
oh okay guys thanks for playing
i'm gonna switch game mode don't do it
doctor
don't do it don't do it don't do it
you got a life to live please
i want to see if i use all the items
what is this then
oh [ __ ] don't join i'm creating a new
game
denzel thanks for joining yeah it's fun
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] wrong one
i didn't mean to join this let's do pvp
[Music]
that way you can get more people in
this one was good
my game was lagging behind you well if
you're in australia i bet
all right
oh i didn't realize there's [ __ ]
pipes jesus
oh
okay let's start it
whoa which pipe to go
to
the [ __ ] is this
let's go
okay i'll take that
you want some hc
hg hg
get me
[Laughter]
need a better weapon
[ __ ] shield i don't want it
you about to get glorious
let the murder begin
one will [ __ ] heal i will heal
this game is [ __ ] up
no my gun
yeah where are you going
where are you going
we're going she's not dead yet
she ain't dead yet
i'm such a [ __ ] [ __ ] giving these
people no chance
sorry sorry
sorry
all right what do you got is that her
head
jesus trophy
[Applause]
it's another gun here i can literally
grab two [ __ ] guns
he's got two shields
thank you he shot him back at me what
the [ __ ]
oh that's pro gamer move
stop the shields are open as [ __ ] what
the
i can't believe this
stop stop the shield
oh [ __ ] she's good again
she's still lying
ah shoot him in the head
shoot him in the head shoot him in the
head shoot him ahead
there it is
oh god oh god i'm out adios
nope stop
yeah two can play that game where did
the guns go
there it is [ __ ] i got a link
oh [ __ ] she's got a good she's gotta go
ricochet i'm fine
i'm fine yes shoot again
stop stop make it
oh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
honestly mate i'm fine there it is
nope
[ __ ]
let's go let's go
that's how it's done that's how it's
done
all right guys gonna wrap up there
that's fun check out the game just style
already
a little bias apparently
it's out on console yeah
nice
they added so much stuff to it i'm
surprised
that's fun
boom
sheesh it's so hot
can you guys hear music i can't hear
anything
there ah
sunscreen fun times
[Music]
innocent firm like the good old days
thanks for joining guys i might stream
tomorrow as well actually
we'll see we'll see
yeah help produce that's right
all right guys see you next time
i should have a video up soon
oh
i was gonna stop and then i [ __ ] up
pull up
god damn it
uh